متواجدين في مدرسه النصيرات الابتدائيه
هنا في مخيم النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه حيث
تاوي هذه المدرسه عدد من النازحين
الفلسطين الذين لجوا اليها جراء الغارات
الاسرائيليه المستمره على المحافظه الوسطى
ولكن قبل قليل وصل هنا عدد من النازحين
الذين جاؤوا من مدينه غزه قادمين بعد ان
اجبرهم الجيش الاسرائيلي على اخلاء
مدارسهم وخاصه في منطقه حي الرمال وايضا
منطقه انصار بعد ان قامت الدبابات الاسرائ
بالدخول الى داخل المدرسه واخراج هؤلاء
المواطنين مشيا على الاقدام بعد التفتيش
الكبير والدقيق لهم من قبل الجنود
الاسرائيليين واجبرهم الجيش الاسرائيلي
على الذهاب الى الطريق الساحلي قدوما الى
مدينه دير البلح وايضا الى وسط قطع غزه
حيث وصل عدد من هؤلاء النازحين الى هذه
المدرسه التابعه لونر وهنا في مخيم
النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه ساعتين ونص مشي
حامل اطفال وحامل غرات حليب ومصاصات
للاطفال ايش حملين احنا
بلا بده يرمي اولاده يعني بده يتحمل
الواحد ايش
نعمل ما لقيناهم الا علينا اجوا خشوا
علينا خبط
البكال وطلعوا كل المدارس ولا خوا مدرسه
كلها طلعوها الحكومه مع مع الوكاله مع كله
كيف طريق
البحر كيف الطريق وانتم جايين خوف رعب رعب
ورعب
وحجاره وشهد مرمي على الارض يعني كنا
مرعبين رعب يعني ايش تصور يعني
كحر يعني بدنا كنا اقل اقل حاجه ندفع اللي
نقعد فيها الامان يعني نقعد فيها مش
قادرين نمشي نكمل
تعبنا ولا اكل ولا فطور ولا فطرنا ولا
تنينا فجا خش علينا وفج زي زل مت وحشين
هنا وصلوا هؤلاء المواطنين وقد جلسوا في
مدارس الاونر ولكن هي ايضا هنا في مخيم
النصرات غير امنه لان قبل قليل حدثت هنا
وبالقرب من هذه المدرسه غارات جويه
اسرائيليه استهدفت مباني للمواطنين
الفلسطينيين بالقرب من هذه المنطقه اشرف
ابو عمره لقناه الجزيره مخيم النصيرات وسط
قطاع غزه